[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're going to be exploring the
question do changing seasons affect your
brain let's get into some season change
I mean we're gonna filter this through
of course Eric's so many years I mean
we're so old some of us older than
others
ha by the time you're listening i've
ever recently I'm 41 oh man I'm not that
old but we both live through many a
season change Rhett and even out I mean
out here in LA things are different
I don't know how seasons work out here I
think maybe we can talk about that you
that's that is actually what got me
interested in talking about this what
got me interested was that it finally
got a little cooler here so I'm like is
it a season yes and no I think it's the
question the answer to question so yeah
we're gonna talk about that about what
it was like in North Carolina what it's
like here and also get into some of the
science around what the the seasons do
to your brain because they do them
things to your brain for real they do
you've got stacks of notes based on love
notes dreams of readings that you've
done I love stacks I just searched some
notes I searched my own psyche for my
experience with fall fall is upon us
some of you listening or deep in the
depths of fall some of you in parts of
the world where it's I don't know it
could be spring that could happen well
that would be all the people in the
southern hemisphere right yeah and we're
not gonna leave you out because we're
gonna talk about seasons changing in
general we're actually going to talk
about the tilt of the earth which is the
reason for the season you want to be
technical about it the reason for the
season okay right is the tilt of the
earth calm down buddy its fasten it down
you getting tilted but before we do that
I want to talk to you about something
that happened yesterday while we were on
a short trip we had a meeting you can
tell him what the meeting is give him
some give him a little window into our
our professional lives man all right
don't be shy
I I don't I don't like that thing works
like we were working on a secret project
first of all it's not a secret part it
is well you know what this is why you're
you you you can't go solo just just so
you know because you would could totally
crash and burn nobody you would say
something you would say something that
we know I wouldn't be here to keep you
from saying it well and maybe it would
be provocative maybe it would be like a
Howard Stern thing and then you'd take
off and have this incredible career
whereas you'll never know he's gonna say
next what we're doing Neal what we're
doing professionally is not provocative
I mean it's just it but it is secret
what I'm saying is that you can say that
we went to a meeting at a place that
makes decisions about what they want on
their particular channel we went to a TV
meeting yes we this is not the first or
the last huh and on the way to the
meeting network meetings man and their
fun and on the way to the meeting
hey get to know us look at us we can
work together on something we pull up
well now you're making it sound like a
general meeting no it was a pitch
meeting Wow
don't tell him that hard that you know
you're just making stuff up it's a pitch
me it wasn't a general it was a pitch
meeting with a specific idea they were
trying to get people excited about all I
was gonna say okay well you just said
maybe we'll work together that's not
what happened it was hey do you like
this idea I was trying to back off of it
after you made me nervous that for some
reason I can you started lying that we
went we have a show idea and we're
having meetings there's an art to
withholding pieces of the truth without
being dishonest
we haven't went too far then you started
lying [ __ ] if you have if you have if
you have a network that's right we have
a show idea that might be right for you
okay there you go
that's innocuous enough and this is
here's the pitch no I think that's what
I'm not I'm not gonna tell him so on the
way to this meeting we pull up to a
stoplight it's link and I and Stevie all
three of us together in my car and we
pull up at a stoplight and I see a guy
get out of his car next to us at a
stoplight and go to the back of his
hatchback and open up the back and the
light was red immediately link gets out
of the car and new
and goes to the man and who's right next
to us and the first thing that I thought
was link has that this man is having a
problem that link can see like link is
the one on that side of the car he can
see that this man needs help and we're
not even saying hold I'm gonna help this
guy I sprung into action
you got out and I'll save the day like
then I see you going directly towards
the man's door that he's in the back of
his car and link is going towards the
open driver driver's door he left his
driver door open and then looks like
he's about to get in the car like oh no
links doing a link joke he's gonna get
shot like that's what I started thinking
yeah I walked towards the open driver
door and then I I was like what what am
I going for here this is the streets of
LA I realize you don't just see a man
get out of his car and then go get in
his car I don't know I can't tell you
what I was legging okay I know exactly
what you think you thought of me after I
thought it would be funny well here's
what happened
so I hear the windows the doors our
doors open so I can hear what's
happening in and link's like I was gonna
get in your car that's what he tells the
guy and then the guy looks at Linc and
he's like such an LA response he's like
funny guy yes I didn't say I was gonna
get in your car did I know you said I
was gonna get in your car but I decided
not to or something yeah truth he was
like funny guy like he wasn't worried he
wasn't scared he wasn't panicking but he
looked at me he knew he was lying to do
and be worried or scared and then you
got back in the car and I said and he
got back in his car
I said couldn't have said it better
myself that's exactly what I was
thinking
funny guy hmm but then you said you did
it to get your mojo up for the meeting
oh yes that was right yeah I'm playing
that to me well you know as I've
out any misgivings have shared freely
with you that we have where we had a
pitch meeting a television network
and I mean it was the first of its kind
for us in many years and I just wanted
to get my mojo up I just wanted to I
just wanted to have like a shot of
adrenaline I just wanted to feel like I
wanted to feel live I wanted to feel
alive I wanted to feel like you wanted
to put a ripple in the universe I wanted
to rip the universe open and to pass
through it and so by potentially getting
in someone else's car I was it that was
a way to get into a different part of
the universe I was never gonna sit down
in his car well I can't say that I did
but I'd I can't say what I was gonna do
because I didn't plan what I was gonna
do he got out of his car he went around
to the trunk I was like wow and before I
knew it I was getting out of the car I
was like you know what just be just go
be instinctive just go with it
engage were smart engage your instincts
for a moment and see what happens and I
found myself standing in the middle of
you know a couple of lanes of traffic
did you size him up was what he looked
like
did it have any impact on your yeah I
see my goodness to get out of the car
and I said he seemed like a nice guy
that I'd like to have a traffic centric
engagement with because he was uh he was
an older guy he's probably in his 50s
and he was shorter than you well I
didn't profile him if that's what you're
asking
well I mean I'm asking the question
because I can't believe how many things
you've done in your life
and still have not gotten punched by a
stranger I mean it's gonna happen at
some point I keep waiting for the day
for it to happen I'm not proud to be
rolling I'm not proud of what I did
because I do feel like it was stupid and
I did have this overwhelming sense of
what if he had to died when I got back
in the car I would have explained that I
would have made up a story just for your
own just for your own legacy I would
have made up a story right I would have
said didn't die he would add this guy
looked like he needed help link got out
of the car and then a guy killed him the
guy away to prison for my legacy no no I
said that he it would've been obvious
that he kills you how he would be guilty
of killing you you know either way
that's true and he may later confess in
prison and be like he just got out of
the car I think it was he was trying to
be funny he's a funny guy and no one
really know he was trying to help you
and I said to get Stevie to go in on it
with me man and and that's why I'm sorry
that I would I mean that I would have I
would have put you in that position just
think about the alternative I'm at your
funeral and I'm like well I know a lot
of you have questions about what
happened to link and I'm just gonna tell
you the story we were at a stoplight a
guy got out of his car and then link
tried to get into his front seat I think
he thought it would be funny
incidentally this is the pitch this is
the show that we then went in I was like
all right a guy stops at a stoplight
it's a reality show it's a prank show
now if you wait for people to get out of
their cars and then you get into their
cars I just I want to grab life by the
ball sack man and I just want to see
where it swings yep he didn't have one
of those hanging from the back of his
truck it was just a hatchback grab life
by the ball sack see where it swings and
sometimes you get you get hung out to
dry and that's what happened you know
what and I regret it
yeah but the thing is I go around I was
like I'm 40 years old what am i doing to
take your analogy all the way going
around grabbing things by the ball sack
is a great way to get punched that's all
I got to say like he'd go out to just a
bull and grab it by the ball sack you're
gonna get bucked man that's what happens
[ __ ] I'm not riding it no you're gonna
get kicked kicked you know I'm saying
you got to be careful about grabbing the
universe's ball sack I really I just
wanted to get pumped up man I mean some
people they you know they do some
calisthenics backstage before they burst
out through that curtain of life
I honestly it was so impulsive I'm I
just wanted I thought that being
impulsive would be something good for
the meeting hmm but you didn't carry
that into the meeting
yeah there's anything spontaneous cuz
you were like what have you died
I mean you buzz kill that man you could
have at least wade into after the meat
you could have been like yeah leak
you're doing it man yeah but if you had
had done something equivalent to that
during the meeting it may have
compromised the pitch what I really want
to know is is there something I could
have said or done when standing out
there that to redeem it because that was
the point where I was like I was just
like floating in the ether of a
commitment to nothing now was it I was
like oh I was like a standing question
mark at the stoplight you coulda said
you need some help and then even been
like no thanks yeah I felt like
something funny could have happened but
that also wasn't what's the funniest
thing that could have happened
mmm I think what happened I think you
should I think you achieved it man okay
well there you go I think that was as
funny as that could be some gotta be
like funny guy did this did talking
about it here redeem it yeah I made it
totally worth it I'm glad you did it
gave us an opening for this episode of
your biscuits I woke up this morning and
I took Jade out hello Jade look a little
visual aid here if you're watching the
video she doesn't seem comfortable with
that I'm holding Jade up Jane will sit
in my lap forever man she's the she's
the perfect she's the perfect thing for
my lap perfect thing for my lap I love
her dude I love her to death
I think about her dying all the time
because I love her so much and I know
that I will outlive her she will die she
will die by you and unless unless you
die I love you maturely which could
happen from doing something in the out
liver so I I try to prepare my heart for
when she's gone and I appreciate every
moment I have with her like right now I
want you to get her cloned man I took
her out to I will that's a good idea
it's getting cheaper and cheaper by the
day I mean seriously you can get the
same exact dog dog clone dot-com slash
ear the soul actually transfers to the
DES clone that's the cool thing about it
that is cool yeah the soul I'm dog will
actually be transmen that was gonna be
my first question so I'm glad you
preemptively answered it I was taking
her out to use the bathroom and I was
like man whoa it's a
a bit no yeah but nipply out here yeah
it's like it's like what 66 degrees whoa
I might need a sweater it was like sixty
degrees when I took her out this morning
to pee pee I'm like man fall is finally
descended upon me right and I just got I
just got I mean I got emotional shivers
down my spine and he started to get
excited man I mean it's what we talked
in an ear biscuit weeks and weeks ago
about you know back to school as a
feeling and I felt a lot of those same
things and like knowing that I know many
of you fall you're in the depth of fall
already the depth of your fault or
you're on the opposite side of the
hemisphere and you're waiting for it but
I just I got this excitement bug man who
I got bit by and I'm like yes I started
immediately thinking about my sweaters
and my jackets I love it you know I love
a good jacket yeah that doesn't you
don't you also wear sweaters and jackets
like the entire summer but now I don't
look crazy yeah right the other night we
were going somewhere with our wives now
we're going to a concert and the first
aid kit concert check him out y'all
first aid love that band sisters from
Stockholm Sweden and sounded great guys
are start on YouTube you know anyway
they're great but we're going to a
concert in it and I had looked at the
weather and the weather said that it
would be like 68 degrees that was a
minimum while we were at the concert and
so I was like that's uh that's light
jacket weather just to give you an idea
of what happens to your body when you
move to Los Angeles is 68 degrees later
hmm I might I don't know about 68 yeah I
might need a light jacket but keep in
mind
light jacket link I'm at my house having
the same conversation with Christie
about yeah Christie Christie tells tells
us at the concert that link she link is
ready to walk out the door and he's got
his like down he's got his down jacket
on that the one like the collapsible you
know like
North Face style yeah the one I kill -
dad I got you Melbourne Australia
typically winter down being if you don't
see like active ice in your vision your
field of vision you're not really
supposed to have one of those on but uh
it was gonna be 68 so well hold on I was
not wearing it and why not because you
walking out the door and Christie busted
out laughing who have people in your
life that keep you from doing dumb stuff
it's good you should be thankful child
locks that's what you need to put on
your your car yes child locks I'll no
passenger seat I don't think that if it
exists man it's only the backseat oh
really yeah
I'll start riding back there okay good
chauffeur me around but you know my
pitch meetings seatbelt locks and men
she started busting out laughs and I'm
like what I was like we just looked up
the weather it's gonna be like it's I
didn't start with a seven
it started with a six right and like I
said I mean I did have a light jacket on
which I already think that to the
majority of the people listening to hear
that it's gonna be 68 degrees and say
that you need a jacket is already crazy
town because 68 is like a setting that
some people have their home on you know
what I'm saying like yeah my mom
probably has it on 68 during the summer
in the house she's not wearing a jacket
well after Christie busted out laughing
I was like okay I guess you're right and
then I just I took it off and I didn't
bring a jacket at all yeah but then you
bought a sweatshirt at the concert and I
put it on immediately yeah and when I
live super faint my wife bought the same
sweatshirt now you guys can't be
together anymore because you might end
up wearing both wear first aid kits
white shirts which would be weird
because people think it's like means
you're like a med person like where are
the two medics that guy's got a first
aid kit in his sweater so does she
ambulance they hold both ends of the cot
what's the cot called the stretcher the
stretcher but they sleep on cuts they
sleep on kinds of mobile thing I don't
think this street don't sleep on this
stretcher but I think the point is is
that when you're in Los Angeles you have
now we're gonna talk about whether or
not there are seasons or not and what
constitutes the season
but we have much less pronounced seasons
than we did in North Carolina what do
you what do you remember from back when
we like experienced like the the the
colors of leaves changing and to me that
much stands out for you me the most
it's your favorite season right yeah the
fall is awesome my favorite season which
is interesting based on what the
research says about how the fall and the
winter make you feel for most people
which we'll get into but it's always
I've always gotten this very like
nostalgic sort of almost excitement when
I feel the weather getting colder again
now I also feel like I get that again as
it gets warmer I feel like the
transition is what I'm excited about I
like change
you like newness but there was always
something about it getting cold at a
time when it was like oh it's my
birthday and then it's Thanksgiving and
Christmas and I'm in school and again I
liked school I didn't like the schooling
part but I liked the whole idea of
school and friends and everything even
if I wasn't willing to admit it to
myself but for me that sort of the
definitive sign was that first frost
which is something that we do not get
out here so all of a sudden one morning
you'd be up you'd be going outside to
get in the car to go to school and then
my parents entire lawn and of course the
neighbor's lawn and then the grass
across the street would all be covered
and ice a layer of like a frost that
would be gone as soon as the Sun hits it
it like melts within minutes but it kind
of like crunches a little bit as you
walk to the car on that centipede grass
and that was in my front yard and there
were those very specific physical
science I mean the changing of the
leaves is one thing you know I'm excited
about we will have already been there
when you're listening to this but going
we haven't yet left for North Carolina
to do the concert but I am excited about
hopefully seeing some leaves I think
some of my colors I think I might pick
up a handful of leaves and just like
crunch them up in
deeply breathe hmm don't don't bring
them back to California that's like a
violation of some sort of interstate cut
thing that sounds like a customs thing
yeah they happen state to state yeah yes
no California customs man they don't
they don't like you to bring in
vegetation I might just stop you at the
border if you have a cactus
I might eat a leaf just to feel the
crunch in my mouth better be careful
summer force I'll spit it out I'll spit
it out to chew it like tobacco
I mean leaf piles man because you know I
was I was avid in the lawn care in my
high school days and man went when those
lit there would be the three-week period
I think where the leaves would just dump
and you would I got this my Papa got
this thing behind his lawnmower which is
long where I used and it was a like a it
was a trailer with a big leaf catcher on
it and had a big rotating thing that
like brushed all the leaves up inside of
it and I could make huge piles of leaves
on the side of the road for like the
town to come pick up any you just run I
mean as a youngster I'd run and jump in
those things man they'd always be dogged
sitting there I distinctly remember that
I would jump in a leaf pile but when did
it get in there before after the pile
was four I think I don't know a little
bit of both I think I've been in a lot
of leaf piles I've never seen any really
Oh without fail I'd find it I think it
was the dog Lauren yeah Nana Papa's
neighbor Kelly had a dog named pepper
and pepper would pepper the leaf piles
me of you know what I mean so he would
go into the leaf laughter I actually had
a fear of jumping and leaf piles after
after a lot of that I'm just realizing
that now that's interesting man I've
never heard anybody talk about that
specific concern it you know it might
have been one of those things might have
happened one time and like now I can't
jump in a leaf pile without thinking
about sinking into some steamy hot
pepper log yeah it's like it's permeated
all of your leaf memories but I still
love it
yeah we don't get a lot of that I'll
tell you something else
remember the exhilaration of going to
the high school football games oh yeah
and it was it was getting cold and you
sit on those bleachers and it was like
okay you know it that was the moment man
you're like you you're walking through
and you see you know who everybody's
there and like you like you like this
girl but you don't want to talk to her
so you're talking to your friends about
her and it's all the drama and no one
watches a football game because our
football team was absolutely horrible I
mean I never once made sense of anything
that was happy when we got if we
actually got a little bit better while
we were there and then they got good
after we left that's right
but they got really hard our high school
football team was in Sports Illustrated
for the longest losing streak of any
high school team and like the I think
that the eighties yeah he's in maybe the
early nineties I mean we were absolutely
awful
but yeah and again I think for me it has
to do with my association with school
and and and sort of like the social I
was really into just oh what is it gonna
be this year like right what do we go to
me and my friends gonna do and it's
different than the back-to-school hope
because by that point we're already unit
you were you were in it and it was it
was uh you're in drama mode it was like
oh what's going on like who's who's mad
at who and well it's that in the other
so I've been talking with Locke about
you know him being back in school and
being in high school and we were talking
about it last night and I was like just
ask him about different aspects of the
day and I remember asking him about
eighth grade and like the way that the
kids ate lunch I I was he would talk to
me about well lunch it did the day I did
this and then we played a little
basketball I was like none of this is
really computing with based on the
understanding that I have of how lunch
went mm-hmm and all of the lunch eating
in California schools or at least in
Southern California schools is done
outside okay so
like the food is served out of windows
that are outside there up under like
some awnings so there's some shelter
just in case there's like the 1 in 100
chance it might be raining but then the
seats are outside yeah and they're
they're there and then they're a lot of
lockers are outside and then the
classrooms you enter in from the outside
and a lot of classrooms and then even if
you don't the buildings are separate and
so you have to go outside and I was
telling like I was like you know the
funny thing is it's like he's like you
guys ate inside I was like of course in
fact in North Carolina at Hornet Central
High School we would go in to school at
8 o'clock and I would not go outside
again until 3 o'clock until why did I
need to go outside there was no reason
to go outside no and it blew his mind
that I was inside all day and I was like
well the reason we were inside all the
days because it's either really really
hot it's either really really really
cold there's bugs all these things don't
really happen here it does get really
really hot here but that's why fall was
such a special time yeah that's what got
me thinking about was that transition
period where it's like all the
mosquitoes are gone you might you might
want to do a little camping right you
know go out to Jordan lake do a little
camping and they just made me think what
what has it done to us we've been out
here eight years now what is it done to
us psychologically being in a place that
doesn't really have seasons because we
certainly pine for it yeah and are we
being damaged by it okay well what I
found is pretty interesting so this is
what typically happens in the fall
winter shift the change of the seasons
into fall and into winter most people
experience or there's a mood shift that
takes place mood shift we're talking
emotions yeah yeah it's okay so HuffPo
interviewed Katherine Rockland I may not
be saying her last name right from the
University of Pittsburgh who cares you
did your best
right and mood shift well she might
during the fall and winter often
includes less energy feeling less social
losing interest in favorite activities
craving carbs and changes in sleep
mm-hmm and there's uh I know that they
probably have done more thorough
research on this but I don't know the
necessarily the adaptive reasons for why
these things happen but the reason that
it happens is the changes in the amount
of light the amount of sunlight that you
are experiencing the length of the day
your body is responding to the length of
the day so that got me thinking so it's
not just the temperature change it's
about the length of the day now Los
Angeles and Fuquay Varina are within one
and a half degrees in latitude so
they're very close we're pretty close so
from a length of day shifts we're
actually experiencing about the same
length of day that we did when we were
in North Carolina so we may not be
feeling and seeing all these indications
of seasons changing but in reality the
days are getting shorter and so we are
susceptible to these same things that
can kind of send you into these places
and in terms of your mood it and there
was another study there's one study was
done it kind of zeroed in on serotonin
show that people produce less serotonin
which is one of the hormones that
regulates mood and contributes to your
feelings of well-being and happiness in
the winter months so the shorter days
can actually bring that down so there's
you know hormonal things that are
happening in your body that can
literally make you feel worse make you
feel it's called seasonal depression
something that happens to a lot of
people and that's it I would think that
be more associated with winter than with
fall well once you've made it through
the transit it's all it's all it's all
constantly changing let me fall is just
a little bit less light than winter and
winter is the peak of of less light so
and then as you started coming out of
that it all starts reversing in the
spring can't trick-or-treat until it
gets dark though so countable
it's all for that but so I thought that
la doesn't have seasons I mean yeah of
course
it like you said you went out this
morning and it felt a little cooler and
it does and it has been really really
hot so it does there is a fluctuation in
temperature but there's not all those
indications well Adrienne Cutler wrote
for curbed said the LA actually has five
seasons
hey what la has an extra season yeah and
they are the winter rainy season okay so
pretty much the only time that it rains
in Los Angeles is during the winter like
I honestly cannot remember the last time
it rained it sprinkled this morning for
a second okay I saw it okay but up until
they're not
but I wouldn't even call that rain but
up until then it's it's it's been since
before summer started that I have seen I
don't remember OP of raina actual rains
yeah so there's a winter rainy season
typically there's the spring there is a
spring and that's sort of what people
who aren't from Los Angeles think of
when they think of Los Angeles which is
like 72 and sunny
that's spring that's classic la weather
but then there's that weird thing the
gloomy early summer like the June gloom
yeah which we experienced I remember the
first year I experienced that I was like
it never rains but it's always cloudy is
that smog and no it's like the marine
layer and there's some weird thing that
happens with the weather systems where
there's just cloud cover that is I
thought the smog was trapped because of
the heat and that's what June gloom was
I didn't know what it's a combination of
both but you don't you're not I mean I'm
smog doesn't get to a place where it
blocks out the Sun right it's not we're
not in Beijing I mean this is they have
five seasons in in China too by the way
they have summer and then they have late
summer are you just like knowledge that
you have from Lily being there are you
just making a joke now no I read and I
read stuff - I just don't print it out
and make a stack like you do and then
there is I don't have anything to prove
this is one of those things that I that
was a shock
the miserably hot late
summer this is what we're just coming
out of I remember the first year we were
here I was like why is it so hot in
September I remember was a hundred
that's the time I'm not I'm not Sofia
there was a hundred and seventeen
degrees in Burbank
yeah the first year that we were here
and I was like what have what have we
done yeah and it was in September yeah
you forget it's a freaking desert and
that has happened many many times la has
gotten very very hot especially when
you're on when you're in the valley
you're on this side of the the hills
that block you from the ocean breeze but
then the fifth season which is actually
the longest technically from October to
April let me guess what it's called
you've already looked at my notes no I
haven't um fall no you haven't said fall
it's the Santa Ana season and so there
is no fall
there's no fall that makes sense yeah
okay that's basically the same we have
five seasons and fall it and even one of
them right we could have six seasons now
we just if we do his wedge fall in there
I Santa Ana yes so Santa Ana this is
something that so I lived in California
when I was four five and six
over in Thousand Oaks which is west of
LA and I remember my mom talking about
the Santa Ana winds oh the Santa Ana
winds are coming again and it was like
this iconic thing and it actually is
this you just do a little googling
around Santa Ana winds there are all
these pop-culture references to it it's
been in songs it's been in movies people
there's a lot of folklore kind of around
it it's on the over 100 years people
have been sort of observing these things
calling it that
leprechauns there's all the no
leprechauns there's all this people
believe things about the Santa Ana winds
and let's say bring but let's say what
they are before we say what okay so I'm
gonna give you the again this is a
Adrian wrote this in this curbed article
and this is exactly how you described it
and this is this is technically what is
happening okay
and from a practical standpoint in the
next couple of weeks we will be at home
in the middle of the night and there
will be a howling wind yes that makes
you think that your roof is going to
come off and
in the middle of the night and crap gets
blown all over the place
things get ruined well if I've got an
umbrella like a patio umbrella but I've
lost to it and you put it down and one
of those square weighted things that's
really heavy and then you you know you
screw it in at the base and it yeah I
remember this - oh it's like the winds
are picking up the weather the only
reason you start to watch the weather is
when they say it's really gonna kick in
right and then I'll go outside and I'll
secure like patio furniture pillows and
I put the umbrella down well that's not
good enough
no it the winds are so strong that the
the umbrella that was down was still
blown over and kind of picked up the
wind didn't go underneath it and like
Mary Poppins it just pushed it over on
the side but still had so much force
that it picked up the entire the
concrete base the entire concrete base
so dangerous took it over top of a chair
and the outdoor coffee table we have and
then burst a palm tree in a huge ceramic
thing that we have and just obliterated
it
I've lost two of those I have a hard
time picking this thing up and look at
mean looking these guns yeah it's
incredible so this is the technical the
technical description Pleasant summer
winds form over the Pacific Ocean okay
but Santa Anas start in the Great Basin
beyond the Sierra Nevadas in the winter
so this is north east of Los Angeles a
long ways away up in the Sierra Nevadas
they form up there in the winter when
the air is cold and the jet stream
leaves behind high pressure systems
which spin clockwise cold and dense
until the heavy air starts to slide down
the mountains towards the coast lower
pressure at the coast helps suck that
cold air through the mountains towards
Southern California so you got this dual
action thing happening with high
pressure and low pressure and as it
cascades down towards the Los Angeles
basin the air heats up dries out and it
speeds up as it snakes its way through
narrow passes and canyons barreling out
finally
the flats blowing 110 miles per hour and
sometimes on 110 degrees some days 110
degrees so you've got wind that's hot
and fast and it is mind blowing to
experience I remember as a kid my
brother and I like wolves howling would
put on our biggest jackets and like hold
our jackets open and lean against the
wind squirrel suit
yeah and just full weight just like
leaning into the Santa Ana winds and
it's just it's just like cultural it
defines Los Angeles in a lot of ways for
an extended period of time it'll blow
the water out of your pool man yeah well
maybe a little bit I mean the top of it
it'll blow the top of your pool so we
did topless so we do have seasons but we
have fun but they're not they're not the
same but we are experiencing so have
you're right so your experiment we've
been talking about experiencing fall and
you just said we don't even have it well
but I want to call it fall we have six
what we do have is we do have the
shortening of the days now let me let us
know hashtag your biscuits is this
something that you experienced do you
let tell us about your experience of
like do you feel a mood shift when when
the days get shorter is there something
that you have experienced I'm I
definitely start to feel a little
sadness when I'm driving home from work
and it's like okay I try to you know I
try to get home by 6:30 which means I
get home at 7:00 and but at least you
tried after all that's what I tell my
wife yeah yeah that she's like why
aren't you here I was a hot tried to be
I tried to get here all the time
and that never works yeah but my
intentions my intention and when it's
dark it it did it makes me more
disappointed it's like I get home at the
same time I would get home in the summer
but it would be light then and I would
just feel like right out you know we
could I could take Jade for a walk but
you don't but you could I
I mean but you could there's all kinds
of things you could do right you know
you don't do anything different right
there's an there's a there's a night
there's a feeling that you could do
things a lot different there's a
vis-a-vis ability yeah yeah you can
watching the sunset I love watching the
sunset from my house yeah
and then the Sun starts setting while
I'm still here working then I get home
and it's just yeah when I go when I
leave the office and it's already dark
it is a little absent there's a sinking
feeling and it and especially after
after Halloween because I because I
can't rationalize the trick-or-treating
thing anymore you know it's like until
then I'm like yeah it's dark how do you
think you would respond if you lived up
in the Arctic Circle and once the winter
came the Sun was by by four months how
do you think he would do in that
situation total darkness totality of the
times there's no Sun that's yeah that's
oh I mean yeah that's horrible that
sound I mean yeah I could definitely see
that that would be depressing okay so
interestingly and by the way don't they
also have the opposite where they'll
have like full 24-hour light yeah yeah
yeah and that can also that can also a
little nuts that are Jeff I think that
Gert drives you like makes you feel
nutty and then when it's dark you just
makes you feel sad well it's my theory
okay so yes that typically they're I
mean there are in credit you know there
are high concentrations of depression in
places that are that experienced these
very very long winters with no Sun but a
woman named Kerry liberal wits Stanford
PhD students been a winter in Norway in
a town called I'm going to mispronounce
this Tromso is what it looks like to me
but I'm sure it's who care
yeah you've tried your best proms Oh
with an O that has like a line through
it
oh you know that's a says ed that's
Canadian for zero mm-hmm Trump zero I
don't think that works but she spent a
year there studying people's mental
health specifically like okay what
like to live up here in this cold place
that's dark for a long periods of time
she wrote a very long extensive article
in the Atlantic I'm gonna give you the
basics here so you would expect them to
be depressed at a higher rate right but
the people in this town do not seem to
be affected by seasonal depression even
though the Sun does not rise in their
winter and she found out that the secret
she theorized is based on being with
them tanning beds hi how did you know is
it no sort of like a light bulb
simulated Sun situation
no like everyone's got a tanning bed
closet no the secret is their mindset
I'm sorry that it's not tanning beds so
anyway they have a a word Casa League
which means cozy and they think about a
part of this winter in terms of Casa
League and in a price inter on the
coziness that you can experience at when
it gets cold when you need to be inside
when you need to be with other people
when you need to be next to a fire when
you need to put on these winter clothes
when you can ski and do I mean it's dark
but they're doing all these things and
so she observed that they looked forward
to winter with a sense of anticipation
to experience this coziness in
relationship with their community other
people and they actually had mood
enhancement and didn't suffer on the
other hand Americans tend to isolate
they tend to complain about the winter
and they actually could they tend to
bond with other Americans by complaining
about the weather in general but
complaining about winter specifically
and so we have a disposition towards
winter in our country where it's like um
it's bad it's cold we we've we've done
this we perpetuate this I don't want to
say it's a myth because I have believed
it that like we go
these cold places and we went to
Minneapolis for our show right and we
went in November it was late October or
November and we were in Minneapolis and
we had to go and and and they have the
tunnels that connect the buildings so
you don't ever have to go outside and
and the sealed bridges but don't hammer
what they're called but the way we
talked about it was like you we had to
go into hell for a limited period of
time until we get back to the wonderful
perfectly warm Los Angeles but it's all
about mindset if you can you can go
through something that is it is very
disciplining but super extreme
experience if you take this mindset and
they take this anticipation of Casa
League into into the winter and it has
this effect where they're happy they've
created and they've created an
experience of coziness that then as a
community they look forward to it
because I mean what again that sir even
the translation of the word cozy is
something well that's so inviting okay
you know it's on a wrap up with that
it's marketing I mean it's like it's
social marketing right to say hey it's
getting to be cozy time these are these
are the activities in the the mindsets
that we have at this time and it becomes
it seems to me you're describing an
elongated holiday I mean you may be
still working I'm sure but I mean I'm
picturing blankets and like special hats
special hats special hats I mean it's
you know I I get so excited if I can do
if I could put a scarf with my jacket or
like when we would go to Sundance Film
Festival every couple of years we'll
we'll head up there and you know I
bought those huge freaking boots yeah
and I I want to go back just a whistle
to where the boot cuz you don't have an
opportunity to because it's so cozy and
it's like I can't do it here like and I
mean I might try to wear them to a
concert in a couple weeks but
do a bit ridiculous skiing I mean I
absolutely love skiing
yeah but they can ski at any time it's
not they don't I don't think so they
don't like snow during the middle of the
summer on them on their big old
mountains uh I don't know I don't know
maybe way up there I picture him like
there I'm talking about for you Oh for
me I mean like that I actually have
found myself really looking forward to
being able to ski now it's gonna be a
little bit complicated oh I agree with
schedules and stuff like that but like
so we're creating things that are you're
saying scheme but creating special
things that only happen are enabled by
this horrible weather enabled by it yeah
and that may just mean sitting outside
with iron aussie by a fire with a big ol
blanket around you well that's another
thing vest in a really cozy blanket well
is having a fire in the house is
something that it really there's maybe a
day or two that it's actually justified
yeah in Los Angeles oh yeah
but it's a magical thing but you'll be
good you'll be going home when it's
again when it's like that was 62 today
and as you're going home you'll see all
the person started a fire they're having
a fire in the fireplace they see the
chimney right because people are looking
and again we noticed this in Australia
too we noticed it in in Melbourne
because it was beginning to be it was
when we went in the end of the summer
it's becoming it was still there was the
peak a winner for them when July was not
cold at all it was it was cold to us
Angelenos and they had on all that
that's why you bought the jacket while
you were there yeah they already had one
and and they were and they were they
were enjoying themselves they were
getting cozy because you naturally want
to experience the season so you
exaggerate the differences that you that
you that are there that are available
people at the equator man they don't
they can't do this I can never put a
jacket on I'm sure there's been studies
of them unfortunately I don't have any
of those in my stacks
what else do you have well I see
something about space yeah well I want
to I want to I want to talk about that
but I want to talk about seasons in
space I do
but one of the really interesting things
I found is that people actually
experience cognitive decline in winter
there was a study of like 3,500 seniors
and not highschool seniors but you know
older people and they experienced a
improvement in cognition during the
summer and autumn and then in the winter
and spring there was a significant
decline because they were studying
people and like when Alzheimer sets in
and like the different parameters for
studying people so you had to assume
that this translates to people so it was
that related you should be doing your
best your best thinking is gonna be done
in the summer well I think I don't know
if that's related to light my theory
would be that with more activity I think
you're getting more you're pumping
around you blood yeah getting that brain
spry er hmm when you're when you're when
you're more active another interesting
thing again that's not necessarily
related what babies are made in the in
the fall speaking of babies speaking of
babies your season of birth is etched
into your brain this is a wired article
so spring babies are more likely to
develop schizophrenia summer babies tend
to grow up to be more sensation-seeking
hey that's me June 1 and scientists
theorize this is due to infants exposure
to viruses over the winter period as
well as the amount of daylight they're
exposed to which might influence genetic
expression during early development and
it's interesting because alright so what
about fall babies well what they
observed in in men only in men is that
if you were born in the fall up and up
until like December the closer you got
to December the more grey matter you had
in one particular part of your brain and
then if you're on the opposite end of
that going all the way up to June which
is when you're born you
less great matter but it wasn't like a
cognitive thing it wasn't a once smarter
it actually contributed to something
something else that it's like your brain
is mush here but it's just in but that
was only a minute didn't apply to women
there were some interesting findings
they don't know and know exactly what to
do with them but basically what you may
have seen this stuff about when you're
born and how it places you into the
school system and what age you are
mmm determines a lot about your future
especially in sports yeah I think it was
a documentary I watched that was about
like every kid who like all the the
hockey players in the NHL like most of
them were born and like I don't know
what the month is but it's based on when
they got into rec league hockey in
Canada based on their age yeah and so
did so but what does that have to do
with seasons no I'm saying you said you
know that but I'm saying it isn't just
that that's a very practical thing I'm
saying
biologically you're affected by the
month that you were born the season that
you were born in oh gosh now your season
I'm you're sneezing you're allergic to
these facts so I'm just saying it was an
interesting thing to find out that with
the season that you're born and actually
into your brain in ways that they're
discovering more and more about but
probably the most interesting thing that
I found is this
space.com which first of all space calm
as a website which is something I was
very I mean it seems obvious that it is
a website but I was very happy to
discover it and actually sad that I had
to be 41 now to be to find space calm is
it a good website though cuz I picture
like a black website with white writing
you're picturing like a 1998 website no
it's it's it's it is bit as black with
white writing it is of course it is his
face doc but it seems like a good
website but there was an article in
there that talked about the tilt of the
earth the tilt of planets and how there
this is a good predictor for whether or
not there might be alien life and we
actually have the tilt of our earth to
think for being here let me explain why
so there are certain things that happen
in the history of a planet that end up
causing a tilt and it's usually is
something about the way it was formed or
some sort of event or something crashed
into it or whatever and basically at
some point a planet becomes tilted in
reference to the star that it's that
it's rotating around that it's in orbit
around and slowly over time the gravity
of the Sun is taking the tilt out of the
planet these terrestrial planets trying
to get it back to normal and just to
clarify so normal would be the tilt is
just defined by the planet itself
spinning and so it's spinning on an axis
that is not perpendicular to the Sun
that is orbiting around yeah well just I
don't want to get into like the fact
that it's orbiting and it's not flatness
until I did let's just simplify it and
say this is the Sun and this is the this
is the planet right here or this is my
mug so I know it's your mug your milk
this would be no tilt and this is tilt
as it goes around and the tilt creates
the seasons right because if you have no
tilt at all what you have is you have
absolute maximum sun exposure in the
equator and then you have it's a
constant absolute and very little sun
exposure in the poles it's completely
indirect light right and it never alters
right and what happens is is over time
yeah good night but you don't have
seasons these initial these initial
events that cause tilt once the tilt
goes away scientists theorize that what
what happens is the atmosphere is
completely annihilated because you have
extreme heat it settles and then you
have extreme cold and it can actually
annihilate the atmosphere and basically
you don't have you don't have a covering
that allows for life and so it's not
dynamic the nation yeah yeah so the
nature of the star like the
gravitational characteristics
of the star different types of stars
determine how quickly that tilt is taken
out of a terrestrial body and so our Sun
is the kind of star that has allowed for
an extremely long period of tilt to
exist which the the seasons and the
atmosphere have what create that could
create the conditions for life to
develop and then like but a red dwarf
star so basically what they're doing is
they're looking out there and they make
these observations about you know
planets that are in the Goldilocks zone
the habitable zone and they're like oh
this is a rocky planet that is about
this distance from this star we can
surmise that there is possibly the
possibility that there's life there but
where they're finding now is that if
that planet isn't tilted a certain way
even if the other conditions seem right
it probably isn't life there and it is
in relate is related to how long it's
been in the system but also the nature
of the star that was just fascinating to
me that was like this tilt this whole
reason that we have these seasons and we
we feel things and we we've adapted and
we've we basically adapt it in the
context of experience in these seasons
it might even be the reason that we're
here to begin with in a space calm Kiko
you gonna have to like regulate that
moment scare the crap out of me I hate
to do that to listeners you know what
they'll go to space calm now I was on
the until you shock me out of it I was
on the board of being inspired by the
tilt of the earth to embrace the seasons
as a form of change a pushing a pull a
pendulum swing that makes life viable
and allows me to embrace change not just
because it's different and I got tired
of what I was experiencing oh it's
cooler I can get too I can wear my
jacket unapologetically with a scarf
hmm
but I was I was toying with thee this is
an opportunity to go even deeper and say
I'm being serious here no I I see what
you're going as a as the seasons change
that it it's a moment to pause and I
don't know in a hokey way maybe just to
be grateful for something on a planetary
level what you just shared hmm it's like
it's a rope thank you for making that
connection to me it's like oh yeah it's
not it's not just my own experience but
our entire planet is viable because of
these changes and I can apply that
analogy to any change in my life perhaps
that would be a stretch but I'll try
well I mean another way to say it is
that what do you hear me saying this
tilt this tilt that creates the change
it makes change a fundamental part of
life is what creates life so life is
change right and getting you know even
even if you're on the equator I mean
obviously it's very static down there
but because of because of the the tilt
even though it may be a static situation
but it's not it's not in in you can you
can live there you know it's not burning
up but I think it's just change is
something that is a there's a part of
life that you can't avoid but it's also
the thing that drives and kind of
creates the energy of life so but and
then how do you runs in ways that you're
you you just change happens it never
happens on your terms and ever happens
in the way that you want to it to happen
but how you interpret it to go back to
the cozy yeah I think is it is a great
point of inspiration for me to say okay
if I find I'm experiencing change
and maybe this is an opportunity for me
to find my cozy like where where is the
cozy in the change because I can't fight
it and to welcome it to wrap yourself up
in anticipate it into welcome it you
know it's again I talk the reason I talk
about this I've talked about a few times
is because I read this book a couple
years ago called the guide to the good
life which was a professor who basically
took stoic philosophy and applied it to
his life like practically he was
teaching it and he was like I'm actually
gonna try to do this and it's an
incredible book and I think there's a
lot that we can learn from the Stoics
but one of the key things that they sort
of they embraced is when you experience
a trial you you see it as a blessing you
see it as something you can be grateful
for because you're like oh this is going
this is a part of the process that it's
going to continue to refine me and to
make me and who I'm supposed to be and I
can just get completely overwhelmed with
the fact that this change that I did not
anticipate that I didn't want that's a
complete inconvenience maybe even a
tragedy is horrible and everything is
horrible that's one approach and the
other approach is to say in fact there's
a book called the obstacle is the way
that was sent to us is that is that Ryan
Ryan Holliday who sent us a bunch of his
book I haven't gotten to that one yet my
wife has read it but basically it just
says that that trial that's actually you
you you should be you should be
anticipating those things in welcoming
those things as they as they happen grab
life by the balls and give it a swing
ball sack that's what you said grab life
by the ball sack and give it a swing and
when the winds of change blow find the
cozy hmm and get a special hat okay a
special hat yeah everybody should have a
special hat mythical doll store oh
that's probably bad timing of acecomm
yeah space
komm gave us a partner of mythical death
stone gave us a turn for the for the
philosophical today yeah and thanks to
I'd like to thank the season of fall
which apparently doesn't exist in this
this Southern California area I would
like to thank the Santa Ana winds that
are gonna blow in at extremely high
temperatures extremely high velocity
well I'm a ballsack off don't go outside
nude man I'm gonna have my strap-on
you'll lose that thing I'm gonna get out
there in the front yard like a sail
leaning into the wind with a jock strap
on and you know what that's me just
embracing the obstacles hashtag ear
biscuits left I'm sorry I apologize for
the for so much scrotal humor yeah
they're still going on but let us know
what you think continue the conversation
not only with us but with other
listeners all you gotta do a search
hashtag ear biscuits that some and and
then start communicating with each other
and with us and of course will speak at
you again next week
yes we will you know what we didn't even
we didn't even mention corn mazes next
episode - hold on mates
hey talk about have you ever been in a
corn maze
[Music]